des grands écarts des roues de la danse
tout seul avec un bâton dans les mains
le twirling bâton était à l'honneur ce
week-end au complexe sportif pierre de
coubertin a plaisir à l'occasion des
demi finales de nationale 2 de la
discipline
originaire des états unis des majorettes
ce sport qui compte aujourd'hui près de
600 licenciés dans les yvelines
nécessite un entraînement intense pour
réaliser les figures pendant les
prestations
il faut d'abord beaucoup de dextérité à
manier le bâton les grosses qualités de
corps donc gymnique corporels pour
pouvoir faire toutes les acrobaties
inimaginable en gymnastique
mais ensuite il faut beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de travail parce que transport
est ingrat le départ à apprendre le
maniement le bâton est ingrat il est en
état lui nous fait parfois un peu mal
quand on gagne pas bien et surtout ils
montent beaucoup beaucoup de travail
comme dans tous les sports 1 grosso modo
et en particulier si on travaille pas
quatre fois par jour
on n'arrive pas au plus haut niveau
national chaque année des dizaines de
tournois sont organisés dans les
yvelines pour remporter la victoire
pendant ces compétitions les toits verts
et wall e s doivent séduire le jury pour
obtenir la meilleure note possible
ils ont un vécu paires de jumeaux
exactement comment gymnastique donc au
nom des pauses notamment pour les
solistes ont déposé un programme avec un
certain nombre de difficultés qui ont
été chiffrés donc on a un code de
pointage que exactement comme la gym et
après ils vont juger de la musicalité
s'il reste la tête et bien
en tempo avec la musique est ce qu'ils
se déplacent correctement par rapport à
di donc c'est pierre potteau de danse et
après bien évidemment le fait de
rattraper le bateau ou par rattraper là
c'est très pénalisant à l'heure actuelle
c'est là aussi c'est comme la nation la
massue elle tombe forcément c'est un
point de pénalité et donc des notes qui
peuvent descendre très bas
prochain rendez vous le 22 juin un grand
gala de twirling bâton sera organisé au
vélotour national de saint quentin en
yvelines